Mitten in der historischen Altstadt
rund um das Rathaus,
erstreckt er sich:
der Aachener Weihnachtsmarkt.
Die meisten der überwiegend
regionalen Händler
verkaufen Weihnachtsdeko
und Geschenke.
Wer kulinarische Spezialitäten sucht,
findet
– neben Glühwein und Punsch –
Deftiges und die süße Aachener Printe.
Das Lebkuchengebäck, hier als Printenmann
in Überlebensgröße,
ist der heimliche Star
des Marktes.
Die Gewürzprinten – man muss sie
einfach mal probiert haben, ne.
Also, um mal zu testen,
wie es denn ist.
Die ganz normalen, die kennt man auch
von zu Hause oder vom Geschäft aus
aber die jetzt hier mit den Gewürzen,
ist schon was Besonderes.
Lichter, Dunkelheit, Glühwein
und was Leckeres essen.
Das ist so für mich Weihnachtsmarkt.
Der Markt im Tageslicht:
im Zentrum das markante Rathaus,
erbaut auf den Resten der Pfalz
von Kaiser Karl dem Großen.
Südlich des Rathauses liegen der Katschhof
und der Aachener Dom:
Er steht auf der UNESCO-Welterbeliste
und ist das Wahrzeichen der Stadt.
Im Norden erstreckt sich der Markt
mit rund 150 Ständen.
Einer von ihnen gehört
der Bäckerei Nobis.
Seit 1858 produziert sie original
Aachener Printen.
Die gibt es heute in vielen Varianten
– mit Nüssen, Mandeln,
Schokoglasuren
und sogar in einer
Karl-der-Große-Edition.
Das Besondere
an den Aachener Printen ist,
dass sie im Stadtgebiet
von Aachen hergestellt,
gebacken worden sind
oder sein müssen
und das hat was mit den
Herkunftsbezeichnungen zu tun,
den geografischen
Herkunftsbezeichnungen.
Das ist in Deutschland
auch geregelt
und deswegen auch geschützt.
Im hinteren Teil der Hütte zeigt
Björn Schröder
in der Schaubäckerei,
wie Domspitzen entstehen:
Printen mit Marzipanfüllung.
Das genaue Rezept für den
braunen Printenteig
ist ein streng gehütetes
Geschäftsgeheimnis.
Die Grundzutaten sind neben
Mehl und Backtriebmittel viel Zucker
– gleich drei Arten:
Sirup, Farin und Kandis
Dazu kommt ein Mix
aus den Gewürzen
Anis, Nelken, Koriander,
Zimt und Piment.
Und die mischt jeder Bäcker
auf seine Art.
Jetzt muss der Teig noch in der
richtigen Dicke ausgerollt werden.
Die traditionelle, ganz normale
Kräuterprinte ist sehr lange haltbar.
Weil da ist kein
verderbliches Lebensmittel drin
Das heißt, da ist weder Ei, Sahne,
Milch [noch] Butter drin.
Nach maximal vierzehn Minuten im Ofen
ist die Basis-Printe fertig
und kann mit Nüssen garniert
oder Schokolade überzogen werden.
Wie heißt das? Plinten?
Printen!
Das ist gut.
Ich denke,
es sind Nüsse darin
Zuerst dachte ich,
es ist nur Schokolade,
aber es ist neben Schokolade
noch etwas anderes drin.
Gut!
Wir haben eine ähnliche Süßigkeit
wie diese in Japan,
auch weich und hart,
auch mit Zimt-Geschmack.
Wir mögen es.
Nicht mein Ding.
Schmeckt mir zu sehr nach Weihnachten.
Man kann dem Weihnachtstrubel
aber auch kurz entfliehen
– mit einem Abstecher in den
Aachener Dom.
Die finden das einfach total süß
und schnuckelig hier,
diese heimelige Altstadt.
Und es gefällt ihnen eben auch,
dass man völlig auf Ramsch verzichtet
und auf so krawallige Weihnachtskirmes.
Und deshalb ist der Aachener
Weihnachtsmarkt auch so beliebt.
Aber die meisten Touristen wollen beides:
die Geschichte der Kaiserstadt
und den Weihnachtsmarkt erleben.